[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy
hi i'm tabitha hey tabitha what's on
your mind
well i have an answer for the question
that ryan opened with and then i have a
question for you joshua so ryan opened
with what are you holding on to and
the short answer is
my starting line you know a start line
of poverty is a stone once cast that
ripples throughout the rest of your life
the effect of basic need scarcity
creates inner obstacles for outwardly
successful people
it certainly burnt the sense of being
overwhelmed in my adult life
i would hesitate or hit pause on big
life events
such as buying a home accepting help and
love and from feeling worthy of things
i'd worked hard to achieve
finding your podcast years ago and
practicing minimalism has calmed the
ripple effect and served me well
i have a rewarding career as a public
servant i'm in a marriage that is true
and beautiful
i'm a proud homeowner though as a
minimalist it doesn't have much in it
um
i found a sense of self-respect and
peace by letting go of a start line that
was never meant to be
my finish line
i've taken ownership of my things my
thoughts my time and my finances and i
want to thank both of you
for pushing beyond your own start lines
and teaching this way of life to me and
others
you've been lovely gods
and you have my gratitude
that's beautiful yeah thank you so much
yeah that's that is beautiful
i got goosebumps
congratulations thank you my question
for you joshua because i i connect most
with your story
does your past life in dayton and
experiencing poverty still affect how
you interact with others now that you
have your needs met
you used a great word yeah hesitation
and
you you would hesitate to make certain
decisions right but then we start to
treat that word as though it's a bad
thing as well we get this weird this
sort of weird conflicting advice right
like uh he who hesitates is lost
right um
and and then so like um and then we have
other people tell us look before you
leap
that just means hesitate
and so
um
i i do look at my upbringing as as
growing up relatively poor i mean
probably in the bottom i don't know two
or three percent of america
um
and it was
it was an unfortunate upbringing and i
certainly learned a lot from that
but i've distanced myself from that not
through well partially through time but
mostly through understanding
that
as you said that start line is not a
finish line
but also realizing there isn't a finish
line now
there were a lot of stories that i told
myself early on
about the reason we're so unhappy
growing up poor is
we don't have any money
and so i tried that i went out and got
the entry level corporate job and i
figured out if you work 80 hours a week
every single week and don't take any
vacations for over a decade you'll climb
your way up the corporate ladder
the happiness won't come with it
we've been told this other lie sold a
lie of success
in our country
in this part of the world what does
success look like if i show you a
magazine ad with a successful person
what what is that person doing or
wearing
they're wearing it's a guy wearing a
suit
and what else are they doing what do
they own
they have a nice car right what else
they always have a watch yeah
what else is like covering up his wrist
right now
they
they always what else do they have
a house right okay they have what
a dog okay a really expensive dog yeah
okay
one of the no one of those like doodle
mixes that cost like two thousand
dollars
what else do they have
i hear kids i heard what
a trophy wife aha
what else
i heard debt let's set that aside for a
second because
here's the thing
the advertisement never shows the debt
a yacht yeah okay so you've got all
these things this all sensible success
right now let me just be clear
there's nothing inherently wrong with
any of those things there are people who
are really passionate about boating who
might find immense value in a yacht
there are other people who feel
compelled to buy a yacht because it says
something about who they are to the
people around them
so
success doesn't really exist not like
that because
that's the that's the
iceberg but it's just the tip there
everything underneath there is the debt
the debt but there's all this emotional
debt too stress anxiety overwhelm
discontent everything that you spent to
get to this picture of success
this is a tether this is a very
beautiful prison that we've put
ourselves in remember was it
who was it
a really expensive um
in colombia the really expensive prison
that um oh pablo escobar yeah escobar
put himself in and so like he
for those who don't know the story he
basically like they put him in prison
but he basically got to build the prison
what a metaphor for what we've done to
ourselves
it's like we're caged behind the white
picket fence right
and it's no wonder we're so
miserable
because we've told ourselves some story
i told myself the story when i was young
oh if i just had money i'd be happy if i
just had success i'd be happy and i got
all the things
and then it was like oh
that didn't make me happy and at first
the impulse is what you know it'll make
me happy if i get rid of the things
wrong
you can get rid of it all right this
isn't about being an ascetic
these austerities for the sake of being
austere don't really
do it either they're not going to make
you happy and this would get rid of the
stuff oh crap
you know what the problem was i didn't
buy the right things
instead of the mercedes i should have
bought the lexus
and then we just go down a different
type of consumerism and so all of these
stories that we tell ourselves they're
disempowering instead of
instead of just creating new
disempowering stories it's about letting
go of those stories as well
question um it brought up
some of my traumas from growing up
and trauma is a weird thing because
i don't know like i used to look at
trauma as
uh these instances that happen and this
created that trauma this created this
drama
yada yada yada but
someone help me reframe it once um
and help me look at trauma like uh like
it's an onion it kind of builds on
itself
it's like this layer that just keeps uh
keeps building
and it's helped me to
just view it in a little bit of a
different way and
for me like to talk to my
to talk to that little kid
like i will seriously like talk to my
five five-year-old self
like it's okay buddy
like what did i need to hear then like
that's kind of how i deal with it but
what it's really helped me appreciate is
that uh and here's the bit the answer
trauma
may happen to you
but you are not your trauma
yes
tk
just building on that i i've heard it
said before that
um
that pain is the experience of
discomfort
suffering is the identification of self
with the experience of pain
pain is inevitable suffering is optional
right
even when we say things like my starting
point my starting point was rough my
starting point was this my starting
point was that
that's not literally true and i don't
say that to me to be like the semantic
version of steve urkel i i
i think there's something important here
for us to understand about the way we
narrate our lives
the starting point literally was like in
the womb of your mother it was you know
when you were born and you don't know
what's going on and you're crying and
somebody's holding you in their arms
that's technically the starting point
and you didn't know anything about
poverty at that moment you didn't even
know what poverty was you had none of
those concepts going on that was the
starting point
so what do you mean and what do we mean
when we use that kind of language and
say my starting point was tough what we
mean is
in the process of narrating our lives
when we look back in the past we find
moments
we find moments and events that seem to
have significance for us there are
moments that really broke our hearts
their moments that really disappointed
us moments that really inspired us and
we are using those moments as the
foundation upon which we will build our
lives and part of understanding the
optional nature of suffering is
realizing that what you are calling a
starting point is negotiable
it's not literally true it's
metaphorically true and the fact that
it's metaphorically true doesn't mean
that it's bad wrong or you need to feel
guilty about it it just means that it's
an expression of your creativity and
since you created it you can uncreate it
you can recreate it you can redefine
your story
second thing i'll say
is that
your starting point is the substance of
your testimony
think about when you go to a movie and
you watch your trailer and they all kind
of start the same people are happy
people are laughing maybe they're
driving down the highway they're hanging
out they're having a good time and how
do you feel completely bored you're not
interested in this movie right
and then the music changes
the lights get dim the camera backs up
and you can tell from the cinematography
that someone is watching these people
having a good time
and we don't know who that is and we
don't know what they're up to and now we
got ourselves a movie yeah now we got
something that you want to see right
because that conflict
is what makes the story interesting that
conflict is what makes the story special
you're not interested if everyone's just
having a good time
and
i think when you think about like these
rough starting points in your life i
just want you to understand that those
rough starting points are the very
things that make your life special when
you figure out how to cope with them or
how to conquer them
you have a testimony that no one else
can replace that's what makes you
indispensable in the world of comedy
the best kind of joke
is the kind of joke that no one can
steal because there are a lot of jokes
that you can steal if you tell a joke
about why the chicken crossed the road i
can take that from you and pretend that
i have it but if you tell a joke about
your daughter i i can't steal it because
it's you
and so when you have a tough starting
point or a moment in your life by which
you define yourself and it seems like
it's holding you back please understand
that that starting point
is what gives you a joke that nobody can
steal but you've got to create the
punchline for it you've got to give
yourself the permission and the power to
decide how you're going to narrate that
yeah we
[Applause]
on the drive up from florida today we
were listening to a philosopher
emil chiran from romania and uh well
some of his work at least
and and ryan and i were just having
these philosophical discussions around
and what was really fascinating about
him is he really liked to hang out with
losers
how did he decide who was a loser anyone
who failed a lot
and he found exactly what you're saying
the failure is so much more compelling
than the success the reason you all are
here tonight is because ryan and i found
some corporate success in our 20s and
you want to figure out how you too can
become a director of operations for a
telecommunications company
no
you you learn you learn from us because
we have these really screwed up
childhoods when you know ryan's
i mean his door was kicked in in eighth
grade the swat team raided his house
because his mom was selling things she
shouldn't be selling
and um
that's part of our history right when we
write in the book about ryan spending
five thousand dollars a month on an
overdosing end up in this mental
institution for a while
this is not a starting point but these
are the this is me and ryan being losers
and showing you
that you can be that but then you can
also
be something else i remember one of our
very first conversations tk
it was not on air but
we were talking about poverty and
growing up poor and no one ever had ever
said this to me before but you said well
poverty is the default state and people
always ask what causes poverty
but why aren't we asking what causes
prosperity
and oh i'm getting chills just thinking
about that man
why don't we talk about that
say what
because it's luck
i i think that downplays how special we
all are
i mean my fundamental conviction in life
is that
each one of us is
part of me but i gotta be me y'all ask
me to come here i believe that each one
of us is is meant to be a unique
individualized expression of divine
brilliance and divine beauty
i know that language doesn't resonate
with everyone but i must speak from
the person that i am right that's what i
believe and that's how i try to treat
people you know it's why i like that
greeting namaste because it means i
salute the divinity within you you know
it's why i like that idea that we're
created in the image and likeness of god
because
when i interact with another person
i'm not talking to someone who can be
below me or beneath me but someone who
is both one with me in some very real
sense but
who is also here to express an aspect of
divinity that when i see i can
experience that awe
you know uh so i i think if we just
dismiss all wealth as luck
we we kind of miss out on the magic of
of what makes us special as human beings
so i think the way i'd approach it is i
would say well first there's a
distinction between abundance and wealth
abundance is any situation where you
have a
plethora of resources right you go to
the the beach you've got an abundance of
sand you go to the ocean you've got an
abundance of water just a lot of stuff
library abundance of books
but abundance isn't wealth because
if that were the case no one would be
poor there are lots of people who live
in very abundant places
but they
their basic needs aren't even met
wealth is when we take the abundant
resources of the universe and we mingle
it with our creativity our imagination
our ascent to possibility and we mold it
and we shape it in a way so that we do
something with those resources that
doesn't characterize their default state
and we share it with another human being
and another human being looks at it and
says wow
that's awesome
can i can i give you something that i
made in exchange for that
or can i give you some money for that
can i say thank you for that can i
reward you for that and
you know when you listen to economists
talk they use these charts and graphs
and they talk about prices and profits
but really
economics is all about the creative
power of the individual it's all about
the magic that happens when people
engage the resources of the universe
with a sense of possibility and say i
will not accept the world as it was when
it was presented to me but i will use
what is within me to make it more so
that when i leave they will say that
brother was here my sister was here
right they showed up
yeah
and that's how we get wealth we we get
wealth by externalizing
the spiritual richness that we came here
with
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free